Support for the This American Life podcast is provided by Anheuser-Busch, introducing Budweiser American Ale, with caramel malted barley and cascade hops from the Pacific Northwest. Learn more at budamericanale.com. And by audible.com, where you can download best-selling audio books, magazines, and radio shows, like this one, to your iPod or mp3 player. Visit audible.com/thisamericanlife today to access over 10 years of our archives, and much more.
This American Life播客由Anheuser-Busch提供支持，隆重推出百威美式艾尔啤酒（Budweiser American Ale），选用来自太平洋西北地区的焦糖麦芽大麦和卡斯卡特啤酒花。详情请访问budamericanale.com。此外还有audible.com，您可以在此下载最畅销的有声读物、杂志和广播节目（如本节目）到您的iPod或MP3播放器。立即访问audible.com/thisamericanlife，获取我们过去10年及更多的精彩存档。
When holiday season began last November, Yvonne started getting it from all sides, friends, family.
去年11月假日季开始时，Yvonne开始从四面八方感受到来自朋友和家人的压力。
I think people look at me sometimes, because I live alone, and think that I'm lonely. Like, tomorrow is Thanksgiving, and I had to really convince everybody that it's OK. I'm going to be home alone on Thanksgiving. Go to Virginia, go to auntie whomever. Do your thing. And I'm going to be fine. Well, you know. No, I'm really going to be fine.
我觉得人们有时看着我，因为我一个人住，就觉得我很孤独。比如，明天是感恩节，我不得不费尽心思去说服每个人这没关系。感恩节那天我会一个人在家。去弗吉尼亚吧，去探望哪位阿姨吧。去做你们自己的事。我会过得很好。好吧，你知道的。不，我真的会过得很好。
Yvonne talked to researcher Allison McKim and our producer, John Jeter. She's lived alone since her kids moved out 12 years ago, and she says it took her five years before she came to actually enjoy it.
Yvonne接受了研究员Allison McKim和我们的制片人John Jeter的采访。自12年前孩子搬走后，她一直独居，她说她花了五年时间才真正开始享受这种生活。
I like the fact that it is self-indulgent. What I want to eat, whether I choose to talk to anybody on the phone, if I want the TV and the radio going at the same time. And I'm not looking at or listening to either one.
我喜欢这种随心所欲的感觉。想吃什么就吃什么，想不想跟人通电话，想不想电视和收音机同时开着，哪怕我根本没在看也没在听。
I enjoy cooking, so cooking is not an issue, per se. But I don't want to have to do anything. And so, I would want to cook when I want to, and I don't even want to compromise on it. OK, so you do Wednesday and Thursday, and I'll do-- No, I'll do it when I feel like it. I want to do everything I feel like doing when I feel like doing it.
我喜欢做饭，所以做饭本身不是问题。但我不想不得不去做任何事。所以，我想做饭的时候就做，我甚至不想在这上面妥协。好吧，你做周三和周四，我做——不，我随心所欲地做。我只想在我有心情的时候做我想做的一切。
It's like killing a waterbug. I'm going to run from it if I'm here by myself. But if, like you two are here, I was like, oh, no. I'll get it. I'll get it. Where's the spray? I can do that with other people, but I can just be the coward that I am when I'm alone.
就像打死一只水虫。如果我自己一个人在这儿，我会躲得远远的。但如果你们两个在场，我会说，噢，没事。我来处理。我来处理。喷雾在哪儿？有别人在时我能做到，但只有我一个人时，我就可以做个彻头彻尾的胆小鬼。
And you don't have to save face.
而且你不需要顾及面子。
Right, exactly. Exactly.
对，没错。确实如此。
When she gets involved with men, they're perfectly fine, she says. But eventually she always decides that she would enjoy being alone more. Though, at first, she was scared to live alone, scared that somebody was going to break in, scared about how she was going to fill her time. That took some getting used to. And these days, she's afraid what's going to happen to her when she gets older, which is something her daughter worries about, too.
她说，当她与男性交往时，他们表现得很好。但最终她总是决定自己一个人过更快乐。虽然起初她很害怕独居，怕有人闯入，怕不知道该怎么打发时间。那需要时间适应。如今，她担心自己变老后会发生什么，这也是她女儿所担心的。
Yeah, she's worried that I'm going to be old, broke, possibly sick, and maybe unhappy that I've made this choice. Like, the rest of them, they want to see me happy, and they don't believe that I can be happy unless I have a companion.
是啊，她担心我会变老、破产、可能生病，而且可能对做出了这个选择感到不开心。就像其他人一样，他们想看到我幸福，他们不相信除非有个伴，否则我不可能幸福。
Every now and then, the thought occurs to me, what if they're right? It does happen every now and then. What if they're right? If this is as good as it gets, right now, and then I'm on to steady decline. You'll have to interview me in 20 years, when I'll say, why didn't you stop me then, when I had a chance? I don't know. I'm good right now.
时不时地，我会闪过一个念头：万一他们是对的呢？这种情况偶尔确实会发生。万一他们是对的呢？如果这就是目前最好的状况，而接下来我将稳步走下坡路。20年后你们得再来采访我，到时候我会说，那时候我还有机会，你们为什么不阻止我？我不知道。我现在过得很好。
Today in our radio show, Home Alone. We have three stories today of people living alone. Act One is the story of detective work in the homes of those who live by themselves. Act Two is about a teenager who ends up living all alone. Act three is about a woman who has to trick an armed man into doing the right thing. It's This American Life , from WBEZ Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. Stay with us.
今天我们的广播节目主题是《独自在家》。今天我们有三个关于独居人士的故事。第一幕是关于独居者家中侦探工作的故事。第二幕是关于一个最终独自生活的青少年的故事。第三幕是关于一个女人不得不诱骗一名武装男子做正确之事的经历。这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《This American Life》，由公共广播国际（Public Radio International）发行。请继续收听。
Act One, A Plot Without a Story. You may remember a couple years back in Chicago, in 1995, over 700 people died after a massive heat wave. And hundreds of them died alone, at home. Well, sociologist Eric Klinenberg wrote a book about all this, called Heat Wave . And he says people die alone like this all the time, all over the country. In fact, big cities have special personnel to deal with those deaths, who travel, Eric says, in the secret society of those who live and die alone.
第一幕，一个没有故事的情节。你可能还记得几年前的1995年，芝加哥在一次大规模热浪之后有700多人死亡。他们中数百人是在家中孤独离世的。社会学家Eric Klinenberg写了一本关于此事的书，名为《热浪》。他说全国各地的人们总是这样孤独离世。事实上，大城市有专门的人员处理这些死亡事件，他们穿梭在Eric所说的那些独居独死者的秘密社会中。
In Los Angeles, the county has an entire department, 100 people, just to manage the bodies and belongings of the deceased. And we sent Eric to LA, to watch what they do.
在洛杉矶，县里有一个完整的部门，有100人，专门负责管理死者的遗体和遗物。我们派Eric去洛杉矶，看看他们是如何工作的。
Mary Ann lived alone, and she died that way, too. She was 79 years old when she called herself an ambulance and went into the hospital. Her life ended there two weeks later, after a full cardiac arrest. She didn't have a friend or relative at her side. In fact, the only person she'd even listed as an emergency contact was this woman, Sue, who delivered drugs for her pharmacy.
Mary Ann独居，最终也孤独离世。她79岁时自己叫了救护车去了医院。两周后，在经历了一次全面心搏停止后，她的生命在那里结束了。她身边没有朋友或亲戚。事实上，她唯一列为紧急联系人的人是这位女士Sue，她是药房的送药员。
I was really surprised when they called me and said that my name was on there as the person to contact. I went, oh, really. OK. I didn't even know if she had a brother or had family.
当他们给我打电话说我的名字出现在上面作为联系人时，我真的很惊讶。我说，噢，真的吗？好吧。我甚至不知道她是否有兄弟姐妹或家人。
Sue last heard from Mary Ann on a phone call from the hospital. She left an urgent message, pleading with Sue to feed and look after her dogs, who were chained up outside the house.
Sue最后一次收到Mary Ann的消息是从医院打来的电话。她留下一条紧急信息，恳求Sue去喂养和照看她那些被拴在屋外的狗。
When she called, she was just crying, because she said, if somebody doesn't pick up the mail, they'll take her dogs away. And she said, they're all I have. She goes, I promise I won't cheat you. I'll pay you. I wasn't worried about that. It just broke my heart a little bit, you know, she would think that that's all she had. That's what she said.
她打电话时一直在哭，因为她说，如果没人去取邮件，他们就会把她的狗带走。她说，它们是我仅有的全部了。她说，我保证我不会亏待你。我会付钱给你。我担心的不是那个。这让我有点心碎，你知道，她竟然认为那是她所有的东西。这就是她说的。
This is the hospital where Mary Ann died. It's been two weeks, and her body's still here. No one's planned a funeral, or even picked up her things.
这就是Mary Ann去世的医院。已经两周了，她的遗体还在这里。没有人计划葬礼，甚至没有人来取走她的物品。
The only personal property left at the hospital, according to their records, is a purse with glasses.
根据记录，医院里留下的唯一个人财产是一个装着眼镜的钱包。
This is Emily [? Issa ?]. She's a deputy investigator for the Los Angeles County Public Administrator, which means she's sort of like a detective for people who die alone. Emily combs through the remains of people's lives, trying to figure out what they left behind and who should get it, searching for next of kin. Emily and her colleagues get 3,000 cases each year.
这是Emily [? Issa ?]。她是洛杉矶县公共行政官的一名副调查员，这意味着她有点像专门处理独居离世者案件的侦探。Emily仔细搜寻逝者生活的遗迹，试图弄清楚他们留下了什么，谁应该得到这些，并寻找近亲。Emily和她的同事每年处理3000起案件。
Hi. I'm here to see Carla Moreno in Patient Services, to pick up some property for a decedent.
您好。我来找患者服务部的Carla Moreno，为一位逝者领取一些财产。
In this case, Mary Ann was single, with no known siblings or children. But she owned her house. She had a bank account, and who knows what other valuables in her home. Now someone stands to inherit it, and it's Emily's job to find out who. She's looking for someone who knew Mary Ann, to lead her to a relative. There's also the question of who's going to bury her. Before Emily's finished, she wants to resolve that, too.
在这个案例中，Mary Ann单身，没有已知的兄弟姐妹或子女。但她有自己的房子。她有一个银行账户，谁知道家里还有什么其他贵重物品。现在有人有权继承这些，Emily的工作就是查出那是谁。她正在寻找认识Mary Ann的人，以引导她找到亲属。还有一个问题是，谁来埋葬她。在Emily工作完成前，她也想解决这个问题。
We start our search at the Patient Services Office. There's a nun working there. And, at first, we think she might know something helpful, because when she sees Mary Ann's name on the case file, her face lights up.
我们从患者服务办公室开始搜索。那里有一位修女在工作。起初，我们认为她可能知道一些有用的信息，因为当她在案件档案上看到Mary Ann的名字时，她的脸亮了起来。
Oh. I know her.
噢。我认识她。
How well did you know her?
您有多了解她？
I just met her a couple of times, was able to visit her. Yeah. Just when she was here. Anyway, so let's just have you--
我只是见过她几次，能够探望她。是的。就在她在这里的时候。总之，让我们……
She ever mention anything about family to you? Did she ever--
她有没有向您提过任何关于家人的事？她有没有……
No.
没有。
The nun hands Emily a big plastic bag. Inside is everything Mary Ann brought with her to the hospital, and Emily starts combing through it, looking for clues. There's a fluffy blue robe, a small black purse.
修女递给Emily一个大塑料袋。里面是Mary Ann带到医院的所有东西，Emily开始仔细搜寻，寻找线索。有一件毛茸茸的蓝色长袍，一个小黑钱包。
There's some medication, some baby powder, just some glasses, typical things you'd find in a female's purse. These are coupons. Here's the ads that she got the coupons from.
有一些药，一些婴儿爽身粉，只是一些眼镜，你在女士钱包里能找到的典型东西。这些是优惠券。这些是她获取优惠券的广告单。
None of this is of much use to Emily. She needs contact information, an address book, a cell phone with some names on the speed-dial. There's nothing like that in the purse. She finds a notebook, and she flips through it in search of a personal note, maybe a list of last wishes. But every page is blank. What she does get is a set of keys to Mary Ann's house. And Emily tells me that the best-case scenario is that, once we get there, we'll find a will or some instructions. That only happens rarely, and in her line of work, it's like hitting the jackpot.
这些对Emily来说都没什么用。她需要联系方式，通讯录，手机里的快速拨号名单。钱包里什么都没有。她找到一个笔记本，翻看着寻找个人笔记，也许是一份遗愿清单。但每一页都是空白的。她确实得到了一串Mary Ann房子的钥匙。Emily告诉我，最好的情况是，一旦我们到达那里，能找到遗嘱或一些指示。这很少发生，在她的工作中，这就像中了大奖。
I've been out to a case where I walked in, and on the night stand next to the bed, it said "In case of emergency." And I opened the envelope, and it had listed everything that I would want to know. And I'm like, wow. That's five minutes and I'm done.
我曾去过一个案发现场，走进屋子，床边的床头柜上写着“紧急情况下”。我打开信封，里面列出了我想知道的一切。我说，哇。五分钟我就搞定了。
Mary Ann's case isn't that easy. When we get to her house, the two dogs are still chained up in the yard, so Emily calls animal control to take them away. The outside of Mary Ann's house is a mess. The wood panels are rotting. There's powdery gray dirt where grass should be. An old Volkswagen minibus with flat tires sits in the dusty driveway.
Mary Ann的案子没那么容易。当我们到达她家时，那两只狗仍然被拴在院子里，所以Emily打电话给动物管理局把它们带走。Mary Ann房子的外部一团糟。木板正在腐烂。本该是草地的地方是一片灰色的尘土。一辆轮胎瘪了的老式大众小巴停在尘土飞扬的车道上。
The inside's even worse. It's dark and dusty, cluttered with stacks of video cassettes, empty juice cans, boxes from the Home Shopping Network, many never even opened.
内部更糟。昏暗且满是灰尘，堆满了录像带、空果汁罐、电视购物频道的盒子，很多甚至从来没打开过。
I'm putting on my gloves so that we can start looking through the house.
我正在戴上手套，这样我们就可以开始搜查房子了。
Emily, who seems completely unfazed by all this, declares it mildly pack-rat.
Emily对这一切似乎完全没受影响，称其为轻微的囤积。
This seems really pack-rat to me. There's not an inch of--
这在我看来确实是囤积。没有一寸地方……
You can walk on the ground. You can still see the ground. We see plenty of cases where you can't even walk on the ground. There is no floor, because it's packed with stuff where you're climbing over.
你可以走在地上。你还能看到地面。我们见过很多案例，你甚至没法踩在地上。没有地板，因为到处堆满了东西，你得爬过去。
Emily is so used to places like this that she never goes on a search without gloves and tennis shoes, not to mention a mask, in case the person died at home and wasn't found for awhile. Usually, she has to dig around.
Emily对这样的地方习以为常，搜查时从不戴手套和穿网球鞋是不可能的，更别提戴上口罩了，以防有人死在家中且有一段时间没被发现。通常，她得四处挖掘。
Emily doesn't just open drawers and medicine cabinets. If she has to, she climbs to the attic. She breaks down locked doors. She once found someone's business records in a refrigerator.
Emily不只是打开抽屉和药柜。如果必须的话，她会爬到阁楼。她会撞开锁着的门。她曾经在冰箱里找到过某人的商业记录。
OK, so let me start poking around here.
好吧，让我开始在这里翻找一下。
Emily is searching through Mary Ann's living room. You can tell she has basically condensed her life into this one area. There's an unmade makeshift day bed in front of the dusty television.
Emily正在搜查Mary Ann的客厅。你可以看出她基本上把生活浓缩在了这一块区域。杂乱的电视机前有一张没整理的临时日间床。
So right now I'm just lifting up all of the different layers of the bed, the padding and blankets that are here. You'd be surprised how many times we actually find people that hide money and things under their bed.
所以现在我正在掀起床上的所有不同层，这里的衬垫和毯子。你会惊讶于我们实际上有多少次发现人们把钱和东西藏在床下。
But there's nothing under there, just stacks of egg crates and musty blankets.
但下面什么都没有，只有成堆的蛋箱和发霉的毯子。
Oh, back here. This is a table and chairs.
噢，在这后面。这是一张桌子和椅子。
There's an entire dining room set hidden under the clutter. Emily seizes on a stack of mail and canceled checks and starts rifling through it, but she doesn't find what she's looking for. No business card from an attorney, no photos of friends or relatives, not even a personal check, just payments to AARP, Ladies Home Journal, TV Guide. In fact, there's not a single sign that there was another person in Mary Ann's life, and I find that much stranger than the mess.
杂物下隐藏着一整套餐厅家具。Emily抓住一叠邮件和已兑现的支票，开始翻阅，但她没有找到她要找的东西。没有律师的名片，没有朋友或亲戚的照片，甚至没有个人支票，只有给AARP、女士家庭杂志、电视指南的付款。事实上，没有半点迹象表明Mary Ann的生活中有另一个人存在，我发现这一点比混乱本身更奇怪。
Is this unusual? I mean, we've now been here for maybe 45 minutes and we've not found a single personal item.
这不寻常吗？我的意思是，我们在这里已经待了大约45分钟，还没找到一件个人物品。
Not at all.
一点也不。
It's not unusual?
不寻常吗？
Not at all. It's hard to describe, but there is a common thread that runs through a lot of our cases, where it's just like this, people surrounding themselves with things, things rather than people. But she's surrounded herself. She almost built herself into a little cave here, behind all of her stuff. And you can tell that this is where she spent most of her time.
一点也不。很难描述，但我们的很多案件中都有一个共同点，就是像这样，人们用东西把自己包围起来，是东西而不是人。但她包围了自己。她几乎把自己建在了一间小洞穴里，藏在她的东西后面。你可以看出这就是她大部分时间待的地方。
Emily's just looking for contact information, not to piece together someone's life story. But sometimes she gets those stories anyway. She tells me about one case that she can't stop thinking about. A woman's husband died in World War II. She survived another 60 years, but her personal correspondence was a record of how she'd tried to avoid moving on.
Emily只是在寻找联系信息，而不是要拼凑某人的生平故事。但有时她还是会得知那些故事。她告诉我一个她无法停止思考的案例。一位女士的丈夫在二战中去世了。她又活了60年，但她的私人通信记录了她是如何试图避免继续前行的。
I found the letters from the military telling her that his plane went down and that they couldn't find him. I found the letter that said, we found his plane now and he's still missing. And then I found the final letter that said, we found your husband's body. And she stopped living. Never remarried. They never had children. I mean, she just was-- it was like a time warp. She just completely cut off the rest of the world.
我找到了军方的信件，告诉她他的飞机坠毁了，他们找不到他。我找到了那封信，说，我们现在找到了他的飞机，但他仍然失踪。然后我找到了最后一封信，说，我们找到了你丈夫的遗体。她就停止了生活。再也没有结婚。他们从未有过孩子。我的意思是，她只是——就像一个时间扭曲。她完全切断了与世界其他地方的联系。
It's remarkable how little we find out about Mary Ann. We learn that her mother once lived with her at this address. There's lots of mail to her. Her father married four times. Her mom was the third marriage. She was into herbal medicine and natural remedies. She had microchipped the dogs. Emily tells me she doesn't want to make a personal connection with the people she's investigating. She doesn't usually try to figure them out, because there are just so many of them. It would be hard to take. But I have to ask.
关于Mary Ann我们了解到的信息之少令人瞩目。我们了解到她的母亲曾经和她住在这个地址。有很多寄给她的邮件。她的父亲结过四次婚。她的母亲是第三任。她喜欢草药和自然疗法。她给狗植入了微芯片。Emily告诉我，她不想和她调查的人产生个人联系。她通常不去尝试弄明白他们，因为人实在太多了。那会很难接受。但我必须问。
Do you ever wonder who she thought would clean this up?
您有没有想过她以为谁会来清理这些？
No. It's never even crossed my mind to think of. Most of the time, you see these people don't want anybody in here. People who knew them never knew that they had this part of their lives that existed.
没有。我从来没想过。大多数时候，你会发现这些人不想让任何人进来。认识他们的人从来不知道他们生活中还有这部分存在。
She must have known that someday she would die, and someone would come in and find all these things.
她一定知道总有一天她会去世，然后会有人进来发现所有这些东西。
Maybe it's just part of her knowing that she has no one to leave it to. Where, who cares about my mess? Because I don't have anyone to leave my stuff anyway, so I might as well leave a mess.
也许这只是她知道自己没有人可托付的一部分。哪里，谁在乎我的烂摊子？因为我反正没人可以留东西给他们，所以我不如留下一片混乱。
After nearly two hours, the only thing we found that might help Emily find a relative is a 30-year-old Christmas card addressed to Mary Ann and her mother. It's from a family in Virginia, and they must be related, because in the card they ask for help with the family tree for the kids. Emily deposits it in a clear plastic bag she'll bring back to the office.
近两个小时后，我们找到唯一可能帮助Emily找到亲属的东西是一张30年前寄给Mary Ann和她母亲的圣诞贺卡。它来自弗吉尼亚州的一个家庭，他们一定是亲戚，因为卡片里他们请求帮忙为孩子们整理家谱。Emily把它放进了一个透明的塑料袋里，准备带回办公室。
Emily seals the front door and walks outside. A few neighbors are looking at us curiously, and she asked them what they know about Mary Ann.
Emily锁上前门走出屋外。几个邻居好奇地看着我们，她询问他们对Mary Ann了解多少。
Did you ever see her? Did she have family?
您见过她吗？她有家人吗？
After more than 20 years, I had never seen no visitors.
20多年了，我从来没见过访客。
This is Luis, who owns the house next door, and he says Mary Ann was never all that friendly.
这是住在隔壁的Luis，他说Mary Ann一直不太友好。
She doesn't seems to be very happy lady. Lonely. A lonely person is not a happy person. She was very lonely most of the years.
她看起来不是个非常快乐的女人。孤独。孤独的人不是快乐的人。这些年来她一直很孤独。
George, another neighbor, had a different take. He thought she was happy.
另一位邻居George有不同的看法。他认为她很幸福。
Yeah, all the time she talked with us. She talked with my son. And every day I come from work, about 3:30, 4 o'clock, and she sometimes on the porch. Hi, Mary. Hi, George.
是的，她一直和我们交谈。她和我的儿子交谈。每天我下班回来，大约3:30、4点，她有时在门廊上。嗨，Mary。嗨，George。
So George thinks Mary Ann was happy. Luis thinks unhappy. Emily tells me this probably says more about Luis and George, and their personal feelings about people who are alone than Mary Ann. There's a stigma against living alone, and an even stronger one against dying alone. I think one reason Emily is so well-suited for her job is that she believes most people live the way they want to live. She may be right, but I'm not so sure. When someone keeps to herself, there's no way to know whether she lived and died outside the reach of friends and family because she preferred it that way or because of things beyond her control.
所以George认为Mary Ann很快乐。Luis认为不快乐。Emily告诉我，这可能更多地反映了Luis和George，以及他们对独居者的个人感受，而不是Mary Ann本身。社会对独居有偏见，对孤独离世的偏见更大。我认为Emily适合这项工作的一个原因是，她相信大多数人过着他们想要的生活。她可能是对的，但我不太确定。当一个人保持孤立时，无法得知她是出于偏好还是因为无法控制的事物而生活和死在亲友触及不到的地方。
Good afternoon. My name is Emily [? Issa ?]. I'm a deputy calling from the Los Angeles County--
下午好。我叫Emily [? Issa ?]。我是洛杉矶县的一名副调查员，致电……
Back in her cubicle, Emily makes a bunch of phone calls. She tracks down the number of the man whose name was on the one clue she found in Mary Ann's house, the 30-year-old Christmas card. His name is Terry. He asked me not to use his last name. But when Emily gets him on the phone, there's a problem. He's got no idea who Mary Ann is. Terry tells Emily to call his ex-wife. She's the one who actually wrote the card. Moments later, Emily's talking to her.
回到工位上，Emily打了很多电话。她追踪到了Mary Ann家里发现的唯一线索——那张30年前的圣诞贺卡上那个人的号码。他的名字叫Terry。他请求我不要使用他的姓氏。但当Emily接通电话时，出了问题。他根本不知道Mary Ann是谁。Terry让Emily给他的前妻打电话。那张卡片其实是她写的。片刻之后，Emily正在和她通话。
Oh, he's the one that gave me the phone number for you, and he said he had never heard of her. So you think that she was his aunt. I see.
噢，是他给了我您的电话号码，他说他从来没听说过她。所以您认为她是他的姑妈。我明白了。
The ex-wife was partly right. Mary Ann was a relative Terry's, but a distant one. Her mother was Terry's great aunt. But Terry had never met Mary Ann, never even spoken to her. And he knew virtually nothing about her.
那位前妻有一部分是对的。Mary Ann是Terry的亲戚，但很疏远。她的母亲是Terry的姑婆。但Terry从未见过Mary Ann，甚至从未和她说过话。他对她几乎一无所知。
We've been just going back and forth on this, trying to figure out, who is this person? And meantime, I went back to the genealogy records, and I found all these Christmas cards. And lo and behold, it was Mary Ann and her mother.
我们一直在来回确认，试图搞清楚，这人是谁？与此同时，我查了系谱记录，找到了所有这些圣诞贺卡。你猜怎么着，上面正是Mary Ann和她母亲。
Terry doesn't hesitate to admit that it was hard to feel emotional about Mary Ann's death.
Terry毫不犹豫地承认，对Mary Ann的去世感到悲伤很难。
My only feeling towards this right now is I feel responsibility to try to resolve her situation, to tidy up her life, I guess.
我现在对这件事唯一的感受是，我感到有责任去处理她的情况，我想，清理她的生活。
One month after Mary Ann died, Terry and his cousins were still deciding whether they wanted the county to settle the estate or handle it themselves. Emily told me that, because Mary Ann's assets total more than $6,000, the Public Administrator would arrange for her to be buried in a local cemetery. But what if she didn't have $6,000? LA County would still take care of things.
Mary Ann去世一个月后，Terry和他的表亲们仍在决定他们是想让县政府处理遗产还是自己处理。Emily告诉我，因为Mary Ann的资产总额超过6000美元，公共行政官会安排她在当地墓地安葬。但如果她没有6000美元呢？洛杉矶县仍然会处理这些事务。
Honored guests, on this day we are gathered here for the annual mass burial, committing to this earthly resting place 1,918 brothers and sisters of humankind who passed away--
尊贵的各位嘉宾，今天我们在此举行年度集体葬礼，将1918位离世的兄弟姐妹安葬在这片大地……
When people die alone here without the money for burial, their bodies are cremated, and their ashes are stored in individual boxes for four years. After that, if no one claims them, the ashes are removed from the boxes and buried together in a mass grave. The burial takes place once a year. This year's ceremony happened just a couple weeks ago.
当人们在这里孤独离世且没有钱支付丧葬费时，他们的遗体会被火化，骨灰被装在独立的盒子里存放四年。四年后，如果没有人认领，骨灰就会被从盒子里取出，合葬在一个集体墓穴中。葬礼每年举行一次。今年的仪式就在几周前举行。
We desire to honor these lives and the deaths of our unclaimed and seemingly forgotten people. Just as--
我们希望能缅怀这些无主且似乎被遗忘的人们的生命与逝去。正如……
We're in the corner of a massive cemetery, right next to a construction site that's torn up the whole street. The service is heartfelt, but a little empty, too. Besides the chaplain, only 10 people, all county employees, showed up for the service. One of them pointed out the tiny plaques that mark each year's grave site. The remains of 1,900 people fill a hole that's 10 feet long, eight feet wide, eight feet deep.
我们在巨大的公墓角落里，就在拆毁了整条街道的施工现场旁边。仪式很真诚，但也有些空旷。除了牧师，只有10个人，都是县里的雇员，出席了仪式。其中一人指出了标记着每年墓地的细小铭牌。1900人的遗骸填满了一个10英尺长、8英尺宽、8英尺深的洞。
Look right over here. Half covered in dirt and sand, you've got 1984, and then three feet away is 1969. And there's 1966. And if we walk up this road, the numbers are going to keep dropping off and off and off, and go decades back. And you think about right here, in the span of just three feet, are the remains of thousands of people. And from 10 feet away, you would never know that these plaques are here.
看这儿。覆盖在泥土和沙子里一半，这是1984年，然后在三英尺外是1969年。那是1966年。如果我们沿着这条路走，数字会不断减少，回溯到几十年前。你会想到就在这儿，仅仅三英尺的跨度内，是数千人的遗骸。离十英尺远，你永远不会知道这些铭牌在这里。
Right here. All these thousands of people who lived alone and died alone aren't alone anymore. Of course, being mourned is a kind of privilege, one that only comes to people who are actually close to other people. Whether they lived alone by choice or by accident, Mary Ann and those 1,918 dead won't get that luxury.
就在这儿。所有这些数千名孤独生活、孤独离世的人们不再孤独了。当然，被哀悼是一种特权，这种特权只属于那些实际上与他人亲近的人。无论他们是出于选择还是偶然独居，Mary Ann和那1918名死者都得不到这种奢侈。
[MUSIC - "TENUOUS GEARS" BY MICALAVERA]
[音乐 - "TENUOUS GEARS" BY MICALAVERA]
Eric Klinenberg is a professor of sociology at NYU and is working on a book called Alone in America . Thea Chaloner did the reporting at Evergreen Cemetery in Los Angeles. In the end, Mary Ann's family said that they're going to step in and take care of everything after her death. They'd be responsible for burying her or cremating her. And they'd clean out her house where, a month after her death, there was still a working phone line, and an answering machine.
Eric Klinenberg是纽约大学社会学教授，正在撰写一本名为《美国孤独》的书。Thea Chaloner在洛杉矶常青公墓做了报道。最终，Mary Ann的家人表示他们会介入并处理她死后的一切。他们将负责埋葬或火化她。他们会清理她的房子，在那里，她去世一个月后，仍有一条工作的电话线和一台答录机。
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话响声]
This is a message phone. No name, no number, no message, no answer.
这是一条留言电话。没有名字，没有号码，没有消息，无人应答。
[MESSAGE BEEP]
[信息提示音]
Coming up, so you're 15 and living by yourself in an apartment, and you need money. So you and a 12-year-old named [? Moochie ?] go in on an investment scheme. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，如果你15岁，独自住在公寓里，需要钱。所以你和一个叫[? Moochie ?]的12岁孩子一起搞了一个投资计划。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际，我们的节目即将继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, Home Alone. And we have, in the second half of our show, two adventure stories of things that happened to people who were home alone. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Boy Interrupted.
这是《This American Life》。我是Ira Glass。今天我们的节目主题是《独自在家》。在节目的下半部分，我们有两个关于人们独自在家时发生的冒险故事。我们现在进入节目的第二幕。第二幕，《被中断的男孩》。
Before we get to what Clevins Browne actually did once he was living completely on his own as a teenager, a couple words about how he ended up that way. Sarah Koenig talked to Clevins.
在我们谈到Clevins Browne作为一个青少年完全独自生活时究竟做了什么之前，先说说他是如何走到这一步的。Sarah Koenig采访了Clevins。
When he was little, Clevins Browne moved all around New York with his mother, to different apartments or homeless shelters. He says a few months was the longest they ever stayed anywhere. His mom would get in a fight with someone, or have a bad experience in a neighborhood, and they were off.
小时候，Clevins Browne随母亲在纽约四处搬家，去不同的公寓或无家可归者收容所。他说几个月是他待在任何地方的最长时间。他妈妈会和某人吵架，或者在社区里有过糟糕的经历，然后他们就离开了。
But all that changed when Clevins was 12. That's when they finally got a subsidized apartment in Brooklyn, in a public housing complex known as the Pink Houses. Clevins says it was the first time he felt like maybe he could be a normal kid. He could invite friends over. He could decorate his own room.
但当Clevins 12岁时，一切都变了。那时他们终于在布鲁克林的一栋补贴公寓里安了家，那是一个被称为“粉红之家”的公共住宅区。Clevins说这是他第一次觉得也许他能成为一个正常孩子。他可以邀请朋友过来。他可以装饰自己的房间。
I was putting up posters of Stone Cold Steve Austin and The Rock. And I also had posters of Kid Rock and Limp Bizkit decorating our refrigerator, stuff like that, stuff that we never really got to do, because since we didn't really own the house we can't really do that. But I just felt a sense of pride to say, hey, this is my wall. I can put whatever I want on my wall, because I own this will. Like, wow, I've never owned a wall before.
我贴上了Stone Cold Steve Austin和The Rock的海报。我还贴了Kid Rock和Limp Bizkit的海报装饰冰箱，诸如此类，我们从未真正做过的事情，因为既然我们不真正拥有这房子，我们就不能那样做。但我感到一种自豪感，说，嘿，这是我的墙。我可以在我的墙上贴任何我想贴的东西，因为我拥有这面墙。就像，哇，我从来没拥有过一面墙。
Clevins says he was happy in the Pink Houses. He liked school, and he had a couple of good friends in the project. And then one day in the spring, when he had just turned 15 and was about to graduate from eighth grade, his mom got sick.
Clevins说他在“粉红之家”很开心。他喜欢学校，在项目里有几个好朋友。然后在一个春日，他刚满15岁，即将从八年级毕业，他妈妈病了。
We were just watching television. We were watching WB. That's basically what my mom and I do every night. We watch the WB, or we watch UPN. And we were watching this one episode of The Fresh Prince . My mother and I have seen this episode a million times. And a joke came on. I forgot exactly what Will Smith said, but it was just one of those jokes that Will Smith said that we would always laugh at, and I just found myself, that I was the only person laughing.
我们只是在看电视。我们在看WB。那基本上就是我和我妈妈每天晚上做的事。我们看WB，或者看UPN。我们正在看这一集《新鲜王子妙事多》。我和我妈妈看过这一集一百万次了。然后出现了一个笑话。我忘了Will Smith确切说了什么，但那只是Will Smith说的我们总是会笑的那种笑话，但我发现，只有我一个人在笑。
And then my mother was just staring at the television blankly. And I said, Mom, you didn't think that was funny this time? And she just remained quiet. And then she asked me to make her some tea, which really, in my house, with her is really skeptical, because my mother never makes me do anything for her. So when she asked me to make her tea, I felt something was wrong. So while I was making her the tea, I just heard her-- I just heard, like, a boom sound. Like, she just hit the floor.
然后我妈妈只是呆滞地盯着电视。我说，妈，这次你不觉得好笑吗？她仍然保持沉默。然后她让我给她泡杯茶，这在我的家里，对她来说真的很反常，因为我妈妈从不让我为她做任何事。所以当她让我为她泡茶时，我觉得出了什么问题。所以当我在给她泡茶时，我听到她——我听到，像是，砰的一声。就像，她重重地摔在了地上。
Next thing you know, I walk into the room and then my mother is just holding her stomach. And she's closing her eyes and clenching her teeth. She's screaming and everything. Now my first initial reaction is to call 911 and run to the house phone, but then I realized that the house phone is disconnected. So I run downstairs and I find a pay phone, and I called 911. The operator responded by saying, 911, what's your emergency?
接下来你知道的，我走进房间，然后我妈妈只是捂着肚子。她闭着眼睛，咬着牙。她在尖叫，等等。现在我最初的反应是打911，跑到家里的电话旁，但我意识到家里的电话断线了。所以我跑下楼找到一个公用电话，我打了911。接线员回答说，911，您有什么紧急情况？
It took me about 10 seconds to respond to her. I mean, I wanted to tell her that there was an emergency upstairs, but at the same time I didn't want to speak up about that. Because I felt that if I spoke up about that, some way, somehow, Child Services would be involved. And that's really the last thing I wanted.
我花了大约10秒钟才回复她。我的意思是，我想告诉她楼上有紧急情况，但同时我不想声张。因为我觉得如果我声张了，以某种方式，儿童保护服务机构就会介入。那真的是我最不想要的事。
Why did you think that?
你为什么会这么想？
I mean, because I felt that if my mother was going to the hospital, then I would basically be upstairs by myself. And I know pretty sure well that I might be taken away or something like that. Like, the law would not allow a minor to be in the house by themselves.
我的意思是，因为我觉得如果我妈妈要去医院，那么我基本上就会独自待在楼上。我很清楚我可能会被带走之类的。就像，法律不允许未成年人独自在家。
Had you ever been in Child Services before?
你之前接触过儿童保护服务吗？
No.
没有。
So you had no experience with that system. It wasn't like, I'm not going back to the foster care, or something like that.
所以你对那个系统没有经验。不是像那种，我不想回到寄养家庭之类的。
I was in foster care, actually, before. But Child Services, I got so many myths about. Like it's just the worst thing in the world. You just don't ever want to be there. So I dialed 911, and the operator on the other line was saying hello three times. And I pretended to be someone else. And I said to the operator, "Um, hello, ma'am. There seems to be an emergency going on in apartment 8D, 1165 Stanley Avenue."
事实上，我以前待过寄养家庭。但关于儿童保护服务，我听说过太多神话。就像它是世界上最糟糕的事情。你永远不想在那儿。所以我拨了911，线那头的接线员说了三声你好。我假装是别人。我对接线员说，“嗯，你好，女士。在Stanley大道1165号8D公寓似乎有紧急情况发生。”
Is that a character you had done before?
那是你以前模仿过的人物吗？
Oh, you want to know the inspiration for the voice?
噢，你想知道那声音的灵感来源吗？
I do.
我想知道。
When I was younger, I was always fascinated at the fact that you can be sitting in a movie theater, and there's always this one voice that you always hear. This summer, coming to a theater near you. And I'm like, who is this guy? Somebody tell me who he is. And growing up I always thought he was this huge muscular dude, like this really, really large man, something like Paul Bunyan almost.
我年轻时，总是着迷于坐在电影院里，总是能听到那种声音。这个夏天，即将在你附近的影院上映。我想，这家伙是谁？有人告诉我他是谁。长大后我总以为他是个魁梧的大个子，就像那种非常、非常高大的人，几乎像Paul Bunyan。
So when you call 911, you're essentially pretending to be Paul Bunyan.
所以当你打911时，你基本上是在假装是Paul Bunyan。
Pretty much. I guess you could say that I'm pretending to be Paul Bunyan making an anonymous tip.
差不多。我想你可以说我在假装是Paul Bunyan在提供匿名举报。
And the operator asked me. She was just asking me all these probing questions.
接线员问我。她只是在问我所有那些刺探性的问题。
Because she doesn't believe.
因为她不相信。
I think she thought it was a prank phone call. So then she asked me again, is there anyone else inside the house with her?
我想她以为那是个恶作剧电话。所以她又问我，屋里还有其他人跟她在一起吗？
"Oh, no. It's just this lady. So I just figured I should just call you guys and let you know." So I run back upstairs, and the situation with my mother is a little bit tenser. She's not screaming at this point. She could actually speak to me. She was like, you need to stop crying right now. Don't worry.
“噢，没有。只有这位女士。所以我只是觉得我应该打电话告诉你们一声。”所以我跑回楼上，我妈妈的情况稍微紧张了一些。她此刻没在尖叫。她实际上可以和我说话。她说，你现在需要停止哭泣。别担心。
Oh, you were crying.
噢，你在哭。
I was crying. And then moments later I'm hearing sirens, and I'm looking out the window. So I told her that the ambulance are here for you. Don't tell them that I'm here. And at this point I just ran into the closet. I was really panicking right now, because I said to myself, Here they come. I can hear their footsteps, and I'm hearing walkie talkies and static. So I just closed the door in the closet. And then, at that point, I was pretty much home alone. They were gone. I'm looking out the window, watching them drive along and everything. And I'm just like, I actually pulled this off. I don't believe that I did that.
我在哭。然后片刻之后我听到警笛声，我看着窗外。所以我告诉她，救护车是来找你的。别告诉他们我在这里。就在这时我跑进了壁橱。我当时真的很恐慌，因为我对自己说，他们来了。我能听到他们的脚步声，还能听到对讲机和静电声。所以我只是关上了壁橱门。然后，在那一刻，我基本上算是独自在家了。他们离开了。我看着窗外，看着他们开车离去等等。我简直不敢相信我真的成功了。我不相信我做到了。
Clevins' mother had a serious stomach illness. Clevins says it was a cyst. But after that was taken care of, she ended up in the psychiatric ward. Clevins doesn't like to talk about it much, but his mom has a pretty long history of mental illness, depression, which accounts for all the moving. She'd been hospitalized for it before. This time, she'd be away for about five months, but Clevins had no way of knowing that or anything about her condition. She couldn't call. Their phone wasn't working. And so he really had no idea what had just happened, where they'd taken her. He barely slept that first night. The next morning, everything just seemed weird.
Clevins的母亲患有严重的胃病。Clevins说是囊肿。但在那之后被处理好后，她最终被送进了精神病房。Clevins不太喜欢谈论这个，但他妈妈有相当长的精神疾病史，抑郁症，这解释了所有那些搬家。她以前曾为此住过院。这次，她将离开大约五个月，但Clevins无法预知这一点，对她的病情也一无所知。她打不了电话。他们的电话不能用。所以他真的不知道刚刚发生了什么，不知道他们把她带到了哪里。第一个晚上他几乎没睡。第二天早上，一切看起来都很奇怪。
I remember leaving the apartment, and everything just looked new to me. In front of my project building there was a sign that says "Hi, you're stepping into Louis H. Pink Houses." And that's a sign I see every single day, but that one day it just looked new to me. I felt older. I just felt like, there's no one here. There's no one that's going to do things for me from this moment on. I have to find out some way to do things on my own.
我记得离开公寓，一切对我来说看起来都是新的。在我的项目大楼前有一块牌子写着“嗨，你正步入Louis H. 粉红之家。”那是我每天都能看到的牌子，但那天它对我来说看起来很新。我觉得自己变老了。我只是觉得，这儿没别人。从这一刻起，没有人在为我做事。我得想办法自己做每一件事。
So you didn't want any of your neighbors to know you were there.
所以你不想让任何邻居知道你在那里。
No.
不想。
Because why?
为什么？
I felt that they would call someone, like a Child Services representative. Because I really didn't want to go anywhere else. Another thing that was really fearing me is that I felt like if I just got up and left, then maybe we would be evicted. But I also knew that I didn't have any money to pay rent, so either way I was sort of stuck.
我觉得他们会打电话给某人，比如儿童保护服务的代表。因为我真的不想去别的地方。另一件让我非常害怕的事是，我觉得如果我就这样起来离开了，那么我们可能会被驱逐。但我也知道我没钱付房租，所以无论如何我都被困住了。
And then how do you-- at what point did you run out of food?
那你——你在什么时候吃光了食物？
A little bit a half month later. And then, there has been a point where I just haven't been eating for days upon days.
半个月后。然后，有那么一段时间我连续几天都没吃东西。
Were you hungry?
你饿吗？
Very hungry. So what I would do is-- during the summer, different schools would have breakfast and lunch every single day-- so what I would do, I would just go to schools, any schools within the area, and just have breakfast and lunch there. And then there were some Saturdays and Sundays where I didn't eat anything at all. Or, if I'm lucky, I would probably get dinner from a friend of mine, like [? Everoll ?], for example, or my neighbor Marie. But there was some Saturdays and Sundays that would pass by, and I'm not eating anything at all.
非常饿。所以我怎么做呢——夏天，不同的学校每天都有早餐和午餐——所以我怎么做呢，我就去学校，去该区域内的任何学校，就在那儿吃早餐和午餐。然后有些周六和周日我根本什么都没吃。或者，如果幸运的话，我可能会从我的一个朋友那儿得到晚餐，比如[? Everoll ?]，或者我的邻居Marie。但有些周六和周日会过去，我根本什么都没吃。
Wow. How long were you without any money at all?
哇。你有多长时间完全没钱？
Two months.
两个月。
Two months?
两个月？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
So were you literally-- like, you did not have a dollar?
所以你真的是——就是说，你连一美元都没有？
Nothing.
什么都没有。
How did you do anything? You live in New York City. How did you get on the subway?
你是怎么做任何事的？你住在纽约市。你是怎么坐地铁的？
Never really got on the subway.
从来没真正坐过地铁。
Did you take the bus anywhere?
你有乘巴士去任何地方吗？
No.
没有。
So what did you do all day?
那你整天做什么？
I was basically just isolated to where I was at, just on my block. That's where I was at every day. Didn't really have any desire to go anywhere, really.
我基本上被隔离在我所在的地方，就在我的街区。我每天都在那儿。真的没怎么有去任何地方的欲望。
And what did you do at night?
你晚上做什么？
I would just be outside, just hanging out. It was summer, and there's no one that's going to tell me that you have to be home at a certain time. So I would just be out. I spent my entire summer just riding my bike, really.
我只是待在外面，只是闲逛。那是夏天，没人会告诉我你必须在某个时间回家。所以我只是待在外面。我整个夏天只是骑我的自行车，真的。
It really was difficult for me to adjust to the fact that my mother's not here. There's no one for me to talk to. Where is she at at this very moment? Is she OK at this very moment? Is she thinking about me at this very moment? And, at times, I would even listen to radio stations that my mother would listen to, even though I totally hated them. They'd play old music from way back in the day. Sugarfly honey bunch. They played The Temptations and all this stuff. So while my mother was gone, I'd just start listening to WBLS. That's the best way I could really make the house lose its emptiness.
适应我妈妈不在身边的事实对我来说真的很难。没人跟我说话。她此刻在哪儿？她现在还好吗？她现在在想我吗？有时，我甚至会听我妈妈会听的广播电台，尽管我完全讨厌它们。它们播放来自很久以前的老歌。Sugarfly honey bunch。她们播放The Temptations和所有那些东西。所以当我妈妈离开时，我就开始听WBLS。这是我能真正让房子失去空虚感的最好方式。
So I really had no money in the house and everything. So [? Everoll ?] and I and a couple of our friends were walking in the street one day, and we found this garbage bag that had boxes of cigarettes inside there. So I have a stick, a little twig, that I'm just walking by, dragging it along the fence. So I see the garbage bag and I started poking it, and just started poking the bag and everything. So then, all these cigarettes, I don't know where they came from, just fall out of the bag.
所以我家里真的没钱，什么都没有。所以[? Everoll ?]和我还有我们的一些朋友有一天在街上走，我们发现了这个垃圾袋，里面有几盒香烟。所以我有一根棍子，一根小树枝，我只是走着，沿着栅栏拖着它。所以我看到了垃圾袋，我开始戳它，只是开始戳袋子等等。然后，所有的这些香烟，我不知道它们从哪儿来的，就从袋子里掉了出来。
Individual cigarettes, or packs?
单支的，还是整包的？
In packs. And then [? Everoll ?] and I made a-- [? Everoll ?] made a joke, actually. He said, How many packs of cigarettes does it take to kill one person? And then I just said, Maybe this is it right here. And then we go home. And then I'm inside my house, just watching TV, and I realized to myself-- I remember on my way upstairs, I saw people smoking cigarettes. And I'm saying to myself, people are wasting their money buying these cigarettes. So I just had to go back and get them.
整包的。然后[? Everoll ?]和我开了个——[? Everoll ?]开了个玩笑，真的。他说，抽多少包香烟能死一个人？然后我只是说，也许这就是了。然后我们回家。然后我在我屋里，看着电视，我对自己意识到——我记得我在楼上时，看到有人在抽香烟。我对自己说，人们在浪费钱买这些香烟。所以我只是必须回去取它们。
And so did you?
那你取了吗？
Mm-hmm. As much as I could. I didn't grab every last one, but I grabbed as much as I can.
嗯。尽可能多地取。我没拿走每一根，但我能拿多少就拿了多少。
And then what did you do?
然后你做了什么？
I went to Marie and I asked her if she would like to buy some cigarettes. And she's like, What you doing selling cigarettes for? I'm like, It's not like I'm selling drugs. These are cigarettes. If the store can sell it, why can't I? So she buys it. And she's like, how much do you want for them? I'm like, $2. So she bought one box. Next thing you know, I have a whole line of people just knocking on my door, asking for cigarettes. And in that one night, I made about $100.
我去找Marie，问她是否想买一些香烟。她说，你卖什么香烟呢？我说，我又不是在卖毒品。这是香烟。如果商店能卖它，为什么我不能？所以她买了。她说，你想要多少钱？我说，2美元。所以她买了一盒。接下来你知道的，我有一整排的人在敲我的门，问我要香烟。在那一个晚上，我赚了大约100美元。
Like any good businessman, Clevins invested some of that money into a new venture, and made a profit of $150, with the help of his friend, [? Moochie. ?] [? Moochie ?] was about 12, but he was shrewd. And he convinced Clevins, the way to make more money was to throw a party at his house and charge people $7 to come. [? Moochie ?] arranged the whole thing, the boom box, the food, which his mom cooked. The clean up and security detail, all [? Moochie's ?] little friends. And it worked, and Clevins was getting by, mostly staying out of trouble.
像任何优秀的商人一样，Clevins把其中的一些钱投入了一个新的风险项目，并在他的朋友[? Moochie ?]的帮助下赚了150美元的利润。[? Moochie ?]大约12岁，但他很精明。他向Clevins建议，赚更多钱的方法是在他家里开个派对，向每个人收取7美元入场费。[? Moochie ?]安排了这一切，音箱，食物，他妈妈做的。清理工作和安保细节，全是[? Moochie ?]的小朋友们。成功了，Clevins靠这个应付了过去，大多待在远离麻烦的地方。
And then at about the two-month mark, he found a permanent solution to the food problem.
然后在大约两个月的时候，他找到了解决食物问题的永久方法。
There is this thing called an EBT card. EBT cards are food stamps.
有个东西叫EBT卡。EBT卡就是食品券。
How did you find the card?
你是怎么找到这张卡的？
Going through my mother's stuff.
翻我妈妈的东西。
Where was it?
它在哪儿？
It was inside her purse that she left.
在她留下的钱包里。
Oh, so she didn't even have her purse with her.
噢，所以她连钱包都没带在身边。
No.
没有。
Oh my God.
天哪。
So basically my mother had this card, and basically that's where all our food was coming from, like she would take this card, go to supermarkets. So I was always under the impression that the code-- because there's a code, a four-digit number code-- I was always under the impression that it was my mother's birthday, 9763. So I took the card to a supermarket, and I swiped the card and I have all this bunch of food and everything.
所以基本上我妈妈有这张卡，而基本上那就是我们所有食物的来源，就像她会拿这张卡，去超市。所以我一直以为密码——因为有个密码，四位数字密码——我一直以为是我妈妈的生日，9763。所以我带这张卡去了超市，我刷了卡，拿了一堆食物等等。
What had you picked out?
你选了什么？
I had picked out tons of pop tarts, cereal, peanut butter and jelly, bread, and all that. And I just throw it on the counter, and I swipe the card in. And I type in 9763. But then the card said, "invalid entry. Read error."
我选了成吨的果酱馅饼、麦片、花生酱和果冻、面包，诸如此类。我只是把它扔在柜台上，刷了卡。我输入了9763。但卡片说，“无效输入。读取错误。”
And before I figured out the access code, I would always go down to the supermarket and just run a test. I would take one item, and see if I could possibly pay for it by entering this access code. So I'm trying to figure it out, and I'm just scavenging through all of her stuff.
在我弄明白访问密码之前，我总是去超市做测试。我会拿一样商品，看看如果我输入这个访问密码是否可能付钱。所以我试着弄明白它，我就在她的所有东西里搜寻。
And my mother has this leather jacket that is a unisex jacket, and I always wanted to wear this jacket. I personally think the jacket looks better on me than it does on her. And I would take this jacket. I would pretend that I'm Shaft. And I had these two cap guns, these two black toy cap guns that I had. So what I would do is I would go in front of the mirror and put the guns inside my coat pocket and pull them out and just start shooting them. And I'm just going through the rest of the pockets. So then I found an envelope that I was about to throw out. And I read it, and it was a letter from the food stamps company, reminding my mother that her access code is this, this, this.
我妈妈有一件皮夹克，是一件中性夹克，我一直想穿这件夹克。我个人认为夹克穿在我身上比穿在她身上好看。我会拿这件夹克。我会假装我是Shaft。我有两把爆竹枪，我有的那两把黑色玩具爆竹枪。所以我怎么做呢，我会在镜子前，把枪放在外套口袋里，拔出来，然后开始开枪。我只是在翻其他口袋。然后我找到一个我正要扔掉的信封。我读了它，那是来自食品券公司的一封信，提醒我妈妈她的访问密码是这个，这个，这个。
And to my surprise, I went down to the supermarket and purchased some food, and it was actually the correct number. Now, what the food stamps card does is that they give you cash and they give you food stamps. I had about $200 in cash and $200 in food stamps. So I was really excited and grateful that this happened.
令我惊讶的是，我去了超市买了一些食物，那真的是正确的数字。现在，食品券卡所做的是，他们给你现金，他们给你食品券。我有大约200美元现金和200美元食品券。所以我真的很兴奋和感激发生了这件事。
All this time, his mom's close friend, a woman Clevins calls Aunt Elizabeth, one of the few adults he'd told about his situation, had been calling around to different hospitals trying to track down his mother. Eventually, she did. Clevins found an old prescription of his mom's, and Aunt Elizabeth called the number and there she was, at Brookdale Hospital in Brooklyn. Clevins rode his bike to go see her. It was pretty upsetting.
这期间，他妈妈的好朋友，一个Clevins叫Elizabeth姨妈的女人，他告诉过的少数几个大人之一，一直在给不同的医院打电话试图追踪他妈妈。最终，她做到了。Clevins找到了他妈妈的一个旧处方，Elizabeth姨妈拨通了那个号码，她就在那儿，在布鲁克林的Brookdale医院。Clevins骑自行车去看她。情况相当令人难过。
There were some other people in there who had some really serious mental issues in there. And it really just made me feel uncomfortable. The people that she's in the ward with, those people are talking to themselves. And I'm always asking myself, why is my mother even with these people? She's really nothing like them. Why is she considered to be one of them? My mother's pretty sane, but these guys are the total opposite.
那里还有其他人有一些非常严重的精神问题。这真的让我感到不舒服。她所在的病房里的那些人，那些人正在跟自己说话。我一直在问自己，为什么我妈妈甚至和这些人在一起？她真的和他们一点也不像。为什么她被认为是他们中的一员？我妈妈相当清醒，但这些人完全相反。
Did you ask her that?
你问她了吗？
No.
没有。
Do you feel like you know why, now?
你觉得你现在知道为什么了吗？
Not really. Still trying to figure that out.
说真的没。还在试着弄清楚这一点。
By this time, the summer was almost over. And even though this whole thing had been hard on Clevins, still, in another way, he had lived the 15-year-old's dream summer. Unlimited freedom, nothing to do but hang out with his friends.
到这个时候，暑假快结束了。即使整件事对Clevins来说很难，但从另一方面来说，他过了一个15岁孩子梦想中的暑假。无限的自由，除了和朋友闲逛什么都不用做。
But now he had to start high school all on his own. He was supposed to go to South Shore High School, which he knew nothing about, not even how to get there. He'd never even really been on the subway without his mom. That first day, he asked the train conductor directions to his school, as if the guy was his personal tour guide. He never made it.
但现在他必须独自开始上高中了。他应该去South Shore高中，他对那儿一无所知，甚至不知道怎么去那儿。他甚至从未在没他妈妈的情况下真正坐过地铁。第一天，他问火车售票员去他学校的方向，好像那家伙是他私人导游一样。他没成功。
But on day two, once Clevins did get there, he was immediately miserable. The place was huge. He says it was like a jungle. And it was so easy to cut classes, which he did, sometimes to go visit his mom. His grades slipped. Most of all, he hated how people at his school saw him.
但在第二天，一旦Clevins确实到了那儿，他立刻就感到很痛苦。那个地方很大。他说这就像个丛林。而且逃课太容易了，他也逃了，有时去探望他妈妈。他的成绩下降了。最重要的是，他讨厌学校里的人如何看待他。
I didn't want to walk in to school being this panicky kid with problems. That's not who I wanted to be. I just wanted to be a regular student.
我不想作为一个有问题的恐慌孩子走进学校。那不是我想成为的人。我只想做一个普通学生。
Did you feel like people would look at you and know, oh, that kid. Nobody's taking care of-- did you look different from other kids? Did you feel like you looked different? Were your clothes dirty or something?
你有没有觉得人们会看着你并知道，噢，那个孩子。没人照顾……你看起来和别的孩子不一样吗？你有没有觉得你看起来不一样？你的衣服是不是脏了之类的？
My clothes were dirty, actually. And I was really antisocial. I didn't really mix myself with other students and all that.
我的衣服实际上是脏的。而且我真的很反社会。我没怎么和其他学生混在一起等等。
Because why?
为什么？
I just didn't feel like-- it just wasn't in me. I felt like I didn't know what direction I was going in. It's like you're being teased. Like, you have something in front of your eyes, but you can't get a hold of it. I'm always able to see my mother and talk to her, but I don't know when she's going to come out. I don't know how long she's going to be there. And that really just drove me insane. I don't know what to do right now. And I never talked to anyone. Never talked to my teachers. There could be times where a teacher-- I'm sitting in a class and a teacher would call my name-- and I would just ignore them, like they're not even there. Like, don't talk to me.
我只是觉得——我只是没那个心情。我觉得我不知道我正朝什么方向走。就像被嘲弄一样。就像，你眼前有东西，但你抓不住它。我总能见到我妈妈并和她说话，但我不知道她什么时候会出来。我不知道她还要在那儿待多久。那真的让我抓狂。我现在不知道该怎么办。而且我从来没跟任何人谈过。从来没跟我的老师谈过。有时老师——我正坐在课上，老师会叫我的名字——而我只是无视他们，就像他们根本不在那儿一样。就像，别跟我说话。
Were are you feeling self-conscious, that people would find out?
你是不是感到自卑，怕人们会发现？
Yeah. I was barely washing my clothes.
是的。我几乎不洗衣服。
Could you tell? Could people tell?
看得出来吗？人们看得出来吗？
Yeah.
看得出来。
Did anyone ever say anything about it?
有人说起过吗？
My guidance counselor. She just said, what's going on? I could obviously see something's wrong with you. That's really a sign of something going on wrong at home, when people don't wash their clothes.
我的指导顾问。她只是说，怎么了？我显然能看出你出了问题。当人们不洗衣服时，那真的是家里出了问题的迹象。
What was your response to that?
你的反应是什么？
I was just like, are you just attacking me? Is that what it is? Until now, I didn't see it-- I saw it as a way, oh, she's just attacking me. She's just trying to judge and disrespect me. So I'm just going to leave her alone. Forget about it. Forget you, too.
我只是说，你是在攻击我吗？这就是吗？直到现在，我没看出来——我把它看作一种方式，噢，她只是在攻击我。她只是想评判和不尊重我。所以我决定离她远点。忘了它吧。你也滚蛋吧。
So did you not go see her again?
所以你没再去见她了吗？
No, I didn't.
没，我没去。
And it was because she said that?
是因为她说了那些话吗？
Mm-hm.
嗯。
And then, one day, the hospital called Aunt Elizabeth and told her Clevins' mom was ready to come home.
然后，有一天，医院打电话给Elizabeth姨妈，说Clevins的妈妈准备回家了。
Prior to that day, the house was extremely messy, and my mother comes home.
在那天之前，家里极其凌乱，而我妈妈回家了。
Were you worried?
你担心吗？
Yeah. I thought she was really going to freak out with the way the house looked. Actually, right before I opened the door, I'm like, Mom, you have to brace yourself for what you're about to see. There are just so many unholy things going on in this house right now that you do not want to look at.
担心。我以为她真的会因为房子的样子而崩溃。实际上，就在我开门之前，我想，妈，你得为你即将看到的做好心理准备。这屋里现在有太多肮脏的事在发生，你不会想看的。
Describe how messy we're talking.
描述一下有多乱？
If you opened the door, imagine you're walking outside on a snowy day, and you have to struggle your ankles to get through the snow. Just substitute the snow with clothes and potato chip bags. And I thought she was just going to be really upset. I was like, Mom, I'm going to take care of this. This is my mess. I'll take care of it. No need to get mad or anything. She didn't get upset. But I looked in her eyes and I felt like this is probably her way, a small way, of making up for the time she spent gone. So that's why she really, really wanted to clean. I've left you alone for this long. This is the least I could possibly do for you.
如果你打开门，想象你在下雪天走到户外，你得费力地挪动脚踝才能穿过积雪。只要把雪换成衣服和薯片袋就行了。我以为她会真的很生气。我说，妈，我会处理的。这是我的烂摊子。我会处理的。没必要生气之类的。她没生气。但我看着她的眼睛，我觉得这可能是她弥补她离开的时间的一种方式，一种小小的弥补。所以我真的很、很想清理。我把你留在这儿这么久。这是我能为你做的最起码的事情。
So I came back just to check up on her. The house is completely spotless. There was no evidence of my five months of garbage piling up in there. She just got rid of it all. The clothes were neatly packed up, the garbage is gone, the floor is mopped and swept. I'm like, what?
所以我回来只是看看她。房子完全一尘不染。没有我那五个月垃圾堆积在那儿的任何痕迹。她只是把它们全处理掉了。衣服被整齐地收好，垃圾消失了，地板也被拖过和扫过了。我说，什么？
Did she ever say anything, directly, about the time you'd been alone? Did you guys ever have a conversation about it?
她有没有直接提到你独自待在那儿的那段时间？你们谈过这件事吗？
Yeah, she kept on apologizing. I said, there's no need for you to apologize. You didn't intentionally say you want to leave me for five months. So it's not your fault.
有，她一直在道歉。我说，你没必要道歉。你不是有意说你想抛下我五个月的。所以这不是你的错。
Was there any part of you that sort of-- Like, obviously, you love your mom and you wanted her to come home, but did you worry that certain things would become harder if she came home, too?
有没有哪一部分你某种程度上——显然，你爱你的妈妈，你想让她回家，但你是否担心如果她回家了，某些事情也会变得更难？
I felt that, when she comes home, I felt like I'm just going to be in the same predicament again one day. I don't know when. But I just knew and felt that it's going to happen again one day. And I just felt like I just want to be more prepared the next time it happens.
我觉得，当她回家时，我觉得有一天我会再次陷入同样的困境。我不知道什么时候。但我只是知道并感觉到有一天会再次发生。所以我只是觉得下次发生时我只想准备得更充分一些。
A few years later, it did happen again. His mom disappeared. Clevins was evicted. But this time, Clevins was 18, and he did handle it a lot better. Since then, Clevins has been living in a friend's apartment. He's working now, and he's planning on going to college next year.
几年后，确实又发生了。他妈妈失踪了。Clevins被驱逐了。但这次，Clevins 18岁了，他处理得好多了。从那时起，Clevins一直住在朋友的公寓里。他现在在工作，并计划明年上大学。
[MUSIC - "SPACE KEY" BY DANIEL LANOIS]
[音乐 - "SPACE KEY" BY DANIEL LANOIS]
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our show.
Sarah Koenig是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Three, The Man Who Came to Dinner. Well, we end our show today with the story of a mother who was home alone with her two small children, when one of the scariest things that can happen actually happens. This was in the early 1980s. Jennifer Schaller was one of the two little children at the time, and she tells the story.
第三幕，《共进晚餐的人》。好吧，今天我们以一个母亲独自带着两个小孩在家，这时发生了最可怕的事情之一来结束我们的节目。这是在80年代初。Jennifer Schaller当时是两个小孩之一，她讲述了这个故事。
There's a story that my mother doesn't like to tell, because it brings back too many bad memories for her. But I love to hear her tell it. It captures her perfectly, how fierce she is. It also shows what was really going on when I was a kid, and I didn't even know it.
有一个我妈妈不喜欢讲的故事，因为它带回了太多糟糕的回忆。但我喜欢听她讲。它完美地捕捉到了她的性格，她有多么坚强。它也展示了当我还是个孩子时真正发生了什么，而我甚至不知道。
We were living in Hightstown, New Jersey, in a one-bedroom apartment in a big courtyard building. It was fall. My brother Alan and I were home from school playing outside. I was five or six, and Alan was a year younger. My mom, Ezra, picks up the story from here.
我们住在新泽西州的Hightstown，在一栋大型庭院建筑的一居室公寓里。那是秋天。我和我哥哥Alan放学在家在外面玩。我五六岁，Alan小一岁。我妈妈Ezra从这儿开始讲。
I was in the house by myself. And then, he knocks on the door, and I open it up. And he identifies himself as one of Raymond's friends, or associates, as they call each other.
我独自在家里。然后，他敲门，我打开了。他自称是Raymond的朋友之一，或者他们所谓的同事。
Raymond is my father. He wasn't around much. My parents told me that it was because of his job as a salesman. I imagined he was a traveling salesman who pushed appliances. I found out later that he was a pusher, but his job had nothing to do with vacuums or dishwashers. When my mother and father first met, he was a legitimate jewelry salesman. Then he traveled to Peru for his father's funeral, and while he was there his half-brother introduced him to the world of cocaine trafficking. The drugs were a constant source of tension between my father and mother, who begged him to stop selling. He promised he would, but never did.
Raymond是我父亲。他很少在家。我父母告诉我这是因为他做推销员的工作。我以为他是推销家电的旅行推销员。我后来发现他是个毒贩，但他的工作跟吸尘器或洗碗机毫无关系。当我母亲和父亲初次见面时，他是合法的珠宝推销员。后来他去秘鲁参加父亲的葬礼，在那里他的同父异母兄弟把他带进了可卡因走私的世界。毒品是我父亲和我母亲之间持续不断的紧张来源，我母亲恳求他停止贩毒。他答应会停，但从来没停过。
At the time this story takes place, Raymond had been gone for more than a week, and my mom didn't know where he was. The man at the door told my mother he had business to discuss with Raymond. He wasn't going to leave until they had settled the matter.
在这个故事发生时，Raymond已经离开一周多了，我妈妈不知道他在哪儿。门口的那个男人告诉我母亲他有生意要和Raymond讨论。在解决这件事之前，他是不会走的。
And at that moment, both you and Alan run up behind him to see who it was that was at the door. And I really didn't know what to say to you guys. So he said that he was actually going to be staying with us for a while. And you guys were satisfied with that. And, you know, Oh, cool. And you just take off and you start playing with your cousins again.
就在那一刻，你和Alan跑在他身后看是谁在门口。我真的不知道该对你们说什么。所以他说他实际上会和我们待上一段时间。你们满足于此了。而且，你知道，噢，酷。你们就走开，又开始和表亲们玩了。
And so, at that point, he comes inside the apartment, and he shows me the gun.
所以在那一点上，他进了公寓，他向我展示了枪。
The gunman said he had to make a phone call, so my mother took him to the phone in the kitchen. She listened to his conversation. It became clear that he was on the phone with his boss in Florida. She overheard him report that Raymond was not around. He said my mom didn't know where my father was or how to get a hold of him. Then he turned to my mom and said his boss wanted to speak with her.
持枪歹徒说他必须打个电话，所以我母亲带他到厨房的电话旁。她听了他的谈话。很清楚他在和佛罗里达的老板通话。她无意中听到他报告Raymond不在。他说我妈不知道我父亲在哪儿或怎么联系他。然后他转向我妈说他的老板想和她谈谈。
The man from Florida never identified himself, never actually gave his name. He just proceeded to tell me that he was very disappointed with Raymond, and that Raymond had disappeared. It'd been four or five days already. Absolutely no communication with him. He had a kilo of coke on him, and it belonged to the man from Florida. So he was concerned about his merchandise and his money. So this is why that man wound up at our doorstep, to help smoke Raymond out.
来自佛罗里达的男人从没表明身份，甚至从没报上名字。他只是继续告诉我是的，他对我父亲Raymond非常失望，而且Raymond失踪了。已经四五天了。和他完全没有沟通。他身上有一公斤可卡因，属于佛罗里达的男人。所以他很担心他的商品和他的钱。所以这就是那人落到我们门口的原因，为了帮忙把Raymond引出来。
I hang up the phone with the guy from Florida, after he had told me that he was going to kill my children and me if Raymond didn't show up. I hang up the phone with the guy and I tell him, well, I guess we might as well get comfortable, because it looks like you're going to be here for a while, because Raymond isn't going to show up anytime soon.
我在和佛罗里达那家伙打完电话后挂断了，在他告诉我会杀了我孩子和我如果Raymond没出现的话。我挂了电话告诉他说，好吧，我想我们不妨让自己舒服点，因为看起来你要在这里待上一段时间，因为Raymond不会很快出现。
When my mom tells the story today, there's a lot of bravado. But at the time, she was terrified, mainly for us. She wanted to keep me and my brother physically safe, but she didn't want this episode to scar us emotionally either. And so she made a decision. She would continue with the ruse as long as she needed to. She carried on normally, as if the gunmen really was an old friend, staying with us for a short time.
当我母亲今天讲这个故事时，有很多虚张声势。但在当时，她非常害怕，主要是为了我们。她想保持我和我哥哥的身体安全，但她也不想让这段插曲在情感上伤害我们。所以她做了一个决定。只要需要，她会继续这场骗局。她照常生活，就像歹徒真的是个老朋友，在我们这儿做客几天。
That evening you guys came in, I made dinner for us. And you and your brother just joked around, because you thought he was a friend of your dad's. So you guys were just being yourselves and joking around and stuff. And I put you guys to bed. And after I put you guys to bed, I went into the bathroom, and I grabbed a towel and I bunched it up and put it on my face. And I started screaming into it, as quietly as I could. And then I started crying. And then, I thought to myself, OK, that's it. This guy can't know that you're upset or that you're fearful. Because the moment he sees fear, he's going to think he's got control. So he's not going to get that control from me.
那天晚上你们进来，我给我们做了晚饭。你和你哥哥只是开玩笑，因为你们以为他是你爸爸的朋友。所以你们只是做回自己，开开玩笑之类的。我把你们送上床睡觉。在我把你们送上床后，我去了浴室，我抓了一条毛巾，把它揉成一团放在脸上。我开始对着它尖叫，尽可能安静。然后我开始哭。然后，我想对自己说，好吧，就是这样。这家伙不能知道你在心烦或害怕。因为他一看到恐惧，他就会认为他掌控了局面。所以他不会从我这儿得到那种控制权。
But how does a single mother with two small kids gain control over a hired gunman? Moments after her tears in the bathroom, my mother saw an opportunity brought about by the television.
但一个有两个小孩的单亲妈妈怎么能控制一个受雇的歹徒呢？在她浴室泪水流下的片刻后，我母亲看到了电视带来的机会。
I wash my face, and I go back out into the living room, and I sat down. And, at that time, it was probably about 8 or 9 o'clock, a movie started on TV, and it was The Godfather.
我洗了脸，我回到客厅，我坐了下来。那时，可能大约8点或9点，电视上开始了一部电影，是《教父》。
I know. The Godfather. Can you believe it?
我知道。教父。你能相信吗？
I started conversing with the guy, and I tell him. I says, yeah, you know. I have an uncle that's in the mafia. As I was telling him this story, his eyes got bigger. And he gets up quietly, and he goes over to the telephone, and he calls the guy in Florida. He's explaining to him, you know, I'm not sure that we should be here in this place with this woman, because she has connections. And he was very nervous. I could see that. And then he comes and he sits down. And I just kept talking, like nothing. And I saw that I had the upper hand at that moment, so I was going to just go with it.
我开始和那家伙交谈，我告诉他。我说，是啊，你知道。我有一个叔叔在黑手党里。当我对他讲这个故事时，他的眼睛变大了。他悄悄起身，走到电话旁，打电话给佛罗里达那家伙。他在向他解释，你知道，我不确定我们是否应该和这个女人待在这个地方，因为她有关系。他非常紧张。我看得出来。然后他走过来坐下。我只是继续说话，就像什么事都没发生一样。我看到在那一刻我占了上风，所以我打算就这样继续下去。
My mother's uncle actually wasn't in the mafia, but his family all believed he was because that's what he told them. He was actually hiding a girlfriend, and later on another family, from his wife. He was a polygamist and not a goodfella. This lie struck a nerve with the hired gunman, who had settled in and slept nights on the sofa. My mother waited on him, bringing him things to eat and drink.
我母亲的叔叔其实没在黑手党里，但他的全家都相信他在，因为他就是这么告诉他们的。他实际上是对妻子隐瞒了一个女朋友，后来还有一个家庭。他是一夫多妻制，不是个好人。这个谎言触动了受雇歹徒的神经，他在沙发上安顿下来，晚上就睡在那儿。我母亲侍奉他，带给他东西吃和喝。
The next day, you guys go to school, and I spend the whole entire day with this guy in our apartment.
第二天，你们去学校了，我和这家伙在我们公寓里待了一整天。
What did you guys do? Just watch TV?
你们做什么了？只是看电视吗？
Pretty much just watched TV, yeah. And, every hour or two hours, the man from Florida would call and try and intimidate me and harass me, asking me where Raymond was and threatening to kill us. And I said, well, I don't know what to tell you, man. But you do what you got to do. If you feel that you got to kill us, then I guess I don't have any control over that.
基本上就是看电视，是的。然后，每隔一两小时，佛罗里达那男人就会打来电话试图恐吓和骚扰我，问我Raymond在哪儿，威胁要杀了我们。我说，好吧，我不知道该跟你说什么，老兄。但你做你必须做的。如果你觉得你必须杀了我们，那么我想我对此没有任何控制权。
This is the point my mother says where her fear turned to rage. She was enraged at my dad for getting us into this mess, at her captor for his intrusion, and at the man on the other end of the phone for his constant threats. So she amped things up a notch. While watching an episode of Miami Vice , she casually mentioned a cousin who was a police detective. This, my mother said, made her captor seem even more nervous. Then she began working on an excuse to see my aunt and uncle who lived in the apartment next door.
这就是我母亲说恐惧转为愤怒的那一点。她对我爸把我们带进这堆烂摊子感到愤怒，对俘虏她的歹徒的入侵感到愤怒，也对电话那头不断威胁的人感到愤怒。所以她把事情升级了。在看《迈阿密风云》一集时，她随口提到了一个当警察侦探的表亲。我母亲说，这让她俘虏的歹徒看起来更加紧张了。然后她开始寻找借口去见住在隔壁公寓的姑妈和姑父。
I had run out of milk. And the guy was insisting that I couldn't go anywhere, and that he had to watch me at all times. And I said well, cool, that's fine, but we need milk for the kids. And I asked him, I said, OK, you won't allow me to go to the store. Can I go right next door to my aunt's house and just ask her for a container of milk? And he just thought about it, and thought about it, and he waves his hand at me and says go ahead, go ahead, but you better be fast. Come back, and you better not be longer than five minutes.
我的牛奶用完了。那家伙坚持说我哪儿也不能去，而且他必须时刻看着我。我说好吧，酷，那很好，但我们需要牛奶给孩子喝。我问他，我说，好吧，你不准我去商店。我可以去隔壁我姑妈家，只要问她要一盒牛奶吗？他只是想了想，又想了想，他对我挥挥手说去吧，去吧，但你最好快点。回来，你最好别超过五分钟。
So I go next door, and I tell my uncle what's going on. And my uncle right away grabs his rifle, one of his rifles, and he says, well, I'm going over there and we're going to take care of this. And I said well, no, I don't want you getting involved in this. I don't want anything to happen to you. So I said, can I use your phone? Let me call Tito real quick.
所以我去隔壁，我告诉姑父发生了什么。我姑父立刻抓起他的步枪，他的一把步枪，他说，好吧，我要过去，我们要处理这件事。我说好吧，不，我不想让你参与进来。我不希望你出事。所以我说，我能用一下你的电话吗？让我快点打给Tito。
Tito was an old family friend. He was working as a delivery man at the time. My mother didn't call the police for two reasons. She didn't want my father to go to jail, and she also feared that her children would be caught up in a violent mess. She called Tito to ask him to drop by so that our captor would know that we had people, that we were not alone. Things ended up working out better than she thought. The gunman mistakenly assumed that Tito was the police detective my mother mentioned earlier.
Tito是一个老家人的朋友。他当时是一名送货员。我母亲没报警有两个原因。她不想让我父亲坐牢，她也害怕她的孩子会卷入一场暴力冲突中。她打电话给Tito请求他顺道来看看，这样我们的俘虏就会知道我们有自己人，我们不是独自一人的。事情最终比她预想的要好。歹徒错误地认为Tito就是我母亲提到的那个警察侦探。
I guess it was because of the clothing that he was wearing. He had on a dark navy blue t-shirt and dark navy blue pants. And he didn't have any type of insignia on his clothing. And so, Tito comes in and he sits down. I introduce him to the guy from Florida. And Tito's, you know, Hi, I just thought I'd come by and see how my comrade's doing, and find out how the kids are doing. I haven't talked to them in a while. So the guy kind of slowly weens his way back towards the telephone in the kitchen, and he's on the phone again. And I tell Tito. I says, Tito, shh. Listen to what he's saying. And he was in a panic. He says, I'm leaving. I am not staying. You do whatever the hell it is that you need to do, but I'm getting the hell out of here because now her cousin, who's the detective from New York City, is here. What the hell am I supposed to do now?
我想是因为他穿的衣服。他穿了一件深海军蓝T恤和深海军蓝裤子。他的衣服上没有任何徽章。所以Tito进来了，他坐下。我把他介绍给了佛罗里达那家伙。Tito说，你知道，嗨，我只是想顺道过来看看我的伙伴怎么样了，看看孩子们怎么样了。我有一阵子没和他们说话了。所以那家伙有点慢慢挪回到厨房的电话旁，他又在打电话了。我告诉Tito。我说，Tito，嘘。听他在说什么。他陷入了恐慌。他说，我走了。我不会待在这儿。随你妈的便你想做什么就做什么，但我正在赶快离开这儿，因为现在她的表亲，那个纽约市的侦探，在这儿。我现在到底该怎么办？
The man on the other end of the phone somehow talked him into staying, and he did for three more days, with me and my brother coming and going to school and my mother waiting on him hand and foot. But by this point, the only person in the house who seemed afraid was the man with the gun, which brings us to what might be my mother's greatest triumph.
电话那头的人不知怎么说服他留了下来，他确实又多待了三天，我和我哥哥来来回回上学，我母亲对他伺候得无微不至。但到了这个时候，屋里唯一看起来害怕的人就是那个拿枪的人，这让我们谈到了可能是我母亲最大的胜利。
My brother and I never suspected any of this was going on. When I think back on this time, I remember going to kindergarten every day. I liked to hug my teacher. My favorite food was pizza, and I was the best speller in my class. I have no recollection of being held hostage by a gunman. Neither does my brother. As a child, I was never angry at my dad for running off with someone else's cocaine. And I don't think this memory is repressed. I think my mother wanted more than anything for my brother and me to believe that our household was like any other, and she succeeded. I only learned what happened that week years later, when I was grown.
我和哥哥从未怀疑过这一切正在发生。当我回想起那个时候，我记得每天去幼儿园。我喜欢拥抱我的老师。我最喜欢的食物是披萨，我是班上拼写最好的。我不记得被持枪歹徒劫持过。我哥哥也不记得。作为一个孩子，我从来没有因为我爸爸带着别人的可卡因跑掉而生他的气。而且我不认为这段记忆是被压抑了。我认为我母亲最想要的是让我和哥哥相信我们的家庭和其他家庭一样，而且她成功了。我直到多年后成年才了解到那天发生了什么。
I didn't show or demonstrate any anxiety. Whenever you guys were around, I was my normal self with you. I would play with you. I would feed you guys. I would read a book to you before you went to bed. And I went about business normally, our daily lives as I normally would. That was pretty much it. That's maybe why you don't remember it ever happening.
我没表现或展示出任何焦虑。每当你们在场时，我跟你们在一起表现得很正常。我会陪你们玩。我会喂你们。我会在你们睡觉前读一本书。我照常生活，像我通常那样处理我们的日常生活。基本就是这样。那可能就是为什么你们不记得它发生过的原因。
On our fourth day as hostages, my father showed up with the money and an explanation which seemed to placate the man who took us hostage, but not my mother. This ordeal stamped out any hope she'd had of reconciling with my dad. The man with the gun was about to leave when my mother went into the backyard.
在我们作为人质的第四天，我父亲带着钱和一个解释出现了，这似乎安抚了劫持我们的人，但并没有安抚我母亲。这种磨难消灭了她与我父亲和解的任何希望。那个拿枪的人正要离开，这时我母亲走到后院。
I had stepped outside into the backyard. I mean, after so many days of being stuck inside the house, I needed fresh air. So I stepped outside, and so the man steps outside. And he says to me, you know, senora, I am so sorry. I hope that you are not going to hold this against me and tell your cousins or your uncle to come after me, because I really didn't want to be a part of this. I was forced into this situation, and ma'am, I really, really, really am sorry about this whole thing. And he grabs my hand, and I thought he was going to shake my hand. He grabs my hand, and he kissed it. That was when I thought, damn, I'm good.
我走到后院。我的意思是，被困在屋里这么多天后，我需要新鲜空气。所以我走到外面，然后那男人也走到外面。他对我说，你知道，夫人，我真的很抱歉。我希望你不会因为这个怀恨在心，或者让你的表亲或姑父来追杀我，因为我真的不想参与其中。我是被迫卷入这种情况的，夫人，我真的、真的、真的很抱歉整件事。他抓住我的手，我以为他要握我的手。他抓住我的手，亲吻了它。就在那时我想，该死，我真棒。
That was the moment, truthfully. That was it. That was when I thought, damn. And to this day, I think about it, and my palms get all sweaty. I was really in the zone. I had my control back. I had taken it back. And it felt great. It really did. It felt really good.
在那一刻，说实话。就是这样。就在那时我想，该死。直到今天，每当我想到它，手心就会出汗。我真的进入了状态。我重新掌握了控制权。我夺回了它。感觉棒极了。真的，感觉真好。
My father went on selling drugs for years. When I was 11, he went to prison. But my mother says this experience changed her. Nothing rattles her even now, she says. Not long ago, a client-- my mom's an insurance agent-- became irate with her, and, from across the desk in her office, threatened her with bodily harm. My mom, all of five foot two, says she stood up, stepped out from behind her desk, and said calmly to the man, Well, have at it. The man walked out of office in a huff and never bothered her again.
我父亲继续卖毒品卖了好多年。在我11岁时，他进了监狱。但我母亲说这次经历改变了她。她说，即使现在也没什么能震住她。不久前，一位客户——我妈是保险经纪——对她大发雷霆，在办公室桌子对面威胁要对她造成身体伤害。我妈，五英尺二英寸高，说她站起来，从办公桌后面走出来，冷静地对那男人说，好吧，来吧。那男人气冲冲地走出了办公室，再也没找过她的麻烦。
Jennifer Schaller lives in New Mexico.
Jennifer Schaller住在新墨西哥州。
Our program was produced today by John Jeter and our senior producer Julie Snyder, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Production help from Seth Lind and Bruce Wallace. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
我们的节目今天由John Jeter和我们的高级制片人Julie Snyder制作，Alex Blumberg，Jane Feltes，Sarah Koenig，Lisa Pollak，Robyn Semien，Alissa Shipp和Nancy Updike参与。Adrianne Mathiowetz运营我们的网站。Seth Lind和Bruce Wallace提供制作帮助。Jessica Hopper提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Yvonne, the woman at the top of our program today, was originally interviewed for Eric Klinenberg's forthcoming book. That research is funded by the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation.
Yvonne，我们今天节目的开头人物，最初是为了Eric Klinenberg即将出版的书接受采访的。该研究由罗伯特·伍德·约翰逊基金会资助。
Our website, where you can get our free weekly podcast, www.thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站，您可以获取我们的免费每周播客，www.thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播国际发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who-- this is so weird. He kept pledging over and over to public radio, hoping that he was going to win a big stuffed doll, until he spent all his savings.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，Torey Malatia先生负责，他——这太奇怪了。他不断地向公共广播捐款，希望他能赢得一个巨大的填充娃娃，直到他花光了所有的积蓄。
Why didn't you stop me then, when I had a chance?
那时候我还有机会，你们为什么不阻止我？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是Ira Glass。下周回来会有更多《This American Life》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，公共广播国际。